Okay.
Today I'm going to talk about Paris.
And in order to talk about Paris and the belly pork in the belly,
pope was not good for,
uh,
for most people in France.
Uh,
it's,
we heard before,
but the image of,
of,
of that nostalgia,
a infused vision of,
of Paris and the belly pork is something that of course comes a,
it really is created.
It's imagined after World War I after World War One.
Uh,
but,
uh,
in order to understand this are the cultural and economic and political and
social dimensions of,
of a fantasy,
Aclu Paris,
we have to back up and look at the rebuilding of Paris in the 1850s and sixties,
uh,
by,
that,
uh,
man dissed by my late friend I Richard Cobb SEL station at Tila.
Uh,
uh,
that is bear an Oarsman,
whose name I should have written on the board but didn't,
but in some of you already know about him,
but it's h a u s s m,
a n,
N as Josh.
And he only went back to Paris three times after he left and financial,
uh,
scandal at the end of the 18,
them a sixties.
And He,
and he lives until,
uh,
until the early 1890s.
But the,
the,
the great boulevards,
it became identified with,
uh,
with modern Paris and on which,
Emilio Marie went on this little walk going out to kill,
um,
have to be seen in the context of the rebuilding of Paris during that period.
And it was the largest urban renewal project,
uh,
in,
at that time in the history of,
of cities,
uh,
really the only ones comparable where the rebuilding of Eto,
that is Tokyo after the great fire,
uh,
and,
London at the time of Christopher Wren.
So we back up even further to look at Paris,
uh,
in a 1837,
just to give you a sense of,
of what changed.
And the first thing you noticed,
particularly if you're comparing it to,
to London or to Berlin,
uh,
is how small a Paris was and help how small Paris still is.
Uh,
this is pre 1860.
So it's before that the inner suburbs were annexed,
which included Mamako out there and a tie and,
and all of the others.
Uh,
and those of you who've been to Paris or know about Paris,
we'll see the,
the job y'all down to on Sambul there,
which was very,
very close to,
uh,
to the city limits at that time.
And then there's the two ways,
three and then the edge of Paris.
There they are,
uh,
the trauma,
which was begun by Napoleon,
uh,
and,
completed,
uh,
during,
the July monarchy.
So,
uh,
Paris tremendously,
overcrowded place and the most densely populated parts of Paris until,
uh,
mid century,
were the,
the,
the evil of CTA that is the island of CFA,
uh,
citv.
There's north Saddam and the,
my hey mer,
ais,
the sort of central right bank,
uh,
districts,
and their population density is three times what it is,
uh,
today.
Uh,
and so the population of Paris,
uh,
which grows so rapidly,
in,
in 1851 is 1,000,050 3000 people,
1861 a year after the annexation of the,
of the inner suburbs,
uh,
is 1,000,690 6,000,
1872,
after the commune,
1 million,
825,000 minus the 25,000 people slaughtered,
uh,
in the wake of the commune during bloody week 1881,
2 million,
269,018 96,
uh,
about two and a half million people.
And so,
you know,
European cities only grow basically in the first two thirds of the 19th century
through migration because more people die in cities than are born there.
A why?
Because of of a unhealthy quarters.
Uh,
uh,
the life expectancy and legal,
for example,
was about 19 years old.
Uh,
the same thing in Manchester or that counts includes infant mortality.
So that's a little bit skewed.
Uh,
but still cities are unhealthy places,
old people,
uh,
the miserably poor people also go to Paris,
um,
uh,
to try to find charity and,
and ultimately to die child abandonment and fantasize and all the things that I
mentioned before,
uh,
disease,
the collar or disease rips through Paris in 1832 and 1849,
again in 1884.
So basically,
I mean,
cities,
large cities replenish themselves only through immigration through a much of the
19th century.
And so what happens is you've got this sort of super hyper overcrowding of the
central districts as a immigrants from the north of France,
from Normandy,
from the east of France,
also seasonal migrants from the Leemoo,
Zach,
uh,
who finally settled in Paris,
poor into the central districts.
And then gradually I had for,
uh,
the edge of a of the city.
Uh,
it's not until the 1880s that you have the huge wave of black,
tall,
uh,
of migration from,
from,
from Brittany.
Uh,
and it's not just a Paris also,
but,
uh,
that,
that comes later then we're talking about.
But so you've got your basic,
uh,
extraordinarily crowded,
um,
uh,
a city,
the ranks of the poor above all,
a swollen by immigration.
The difference,
one of the differences between the 19th century and now for example,
is in the 19th century,
uh,
most people,
the people coming into Paris were already poor.
We're poor than the people who are already there.
Now in the 1950s,
in 1960s,
that changes the 1950s in 1960s,
you have these young Cooper,
you have,
you know,
young,
married couples,
upwardly mobile,
uh,
who come to Paris with enough money that they've put together to rent and then
finally maybe to buy an apartment,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But,
uh,
you have a mass of,
of,
of poor people,
masses of poor people coming,
uh,
into Paris.
And Paris is unhealthy.
This I put in,
I mean,
this is how I handle handball in fact,
but this is,
I mean,
this is a,
um,
you know,
I,
I've said before about how you just try to imagine what things are like until
you can see actually for the first time,
this is the first photo of Paris.
This is a guy teeth.
It was a primitive kind of photo.
This is a,
you can identify this as,
as the rue a as a full blown do Tom,
uh,
on the edge of Paris.
And this is a 18,
uh,
a 1837,
but here's your,
your classic sort of image of,
of,
of urban,
urban poverty,
urban squalor,
the kind of gray kind of gray,
uh,
images of a street that no longer exists.
Uh,
uh,
because of ost months rebuilding.
This was behind the Ponti.
All that is,
uh,
just soar above of the Latin quarter.
And you see this ditch running right down the,
uh,
right down the street.
I mean,
he carried sewage.
there were,
there were already sewers in Paris,
but it was terribly unhealthy.
And you're,
you're thinking,
oh,
why,
you know,
he says it's so crowded,
but we're all the people,
you know,
it looks like there's nobody there will,
in fact,
it's because it took so long to expose,
you know,
photos that there actually,
you look very closely,
you can see some people.
But there's another reason why they're not a lot of people about or any signs of
life is that this has already been targeted for demolition.
And the people have had to move out of what was already a poor neighborhood,
uh,
to find an even poorer one on the margins of urban life.
That is the photography.
That was a photograph by shot on amount of veal.
Um,
and here we got the,
you know,
Louis Napoleon,
your basic picture of,
of uh,
uh,
Louis Napoleon,
for once,
not at the opera,
tried to,
tried to hit on the young ballerinas.
Uh,
and the man in the middle is ost mine,
uh,
who was not born in Alsace.
Uh,
but his family came from Alsace and he'd been a law student in Paris and he was
born in the more prosperous western part of Paris.
Again,
the dichotomy between prosperous west and and a more impoverished east is as
important as increasingly a prosper center,
uh,
over the long run of time and the impoverished periphery.
More about that in a minute.
So,
uh,
in 1852,
Napoleon,
uh,
spreads out a map of a city he really didn't know very well and Napoleon the
third desk and says,
I want you to build me great boulevards.
And so,
oh,
smart,
who's prefect of the sin does that.
Uh,
and it's a time when the wealthy got wealthier that,
that,
uh,
in the,
the poor did a better working class,
people did better.
Uh,
but the gap between the rich and the poor,
uh,
increased.
So the,
now if you're looking later in,
uh,
you know,
an 1855,
you see that the city had expanded,
but you still have the wall around Paris,
uh,
and you still have these sort of rural areas within,
within the city.
And one of the points of this is that that's continuing implosion of population
into Paris.
Uh,
and the eviction high prices and by demolition with the rebuilding of Paris is
going to push people out into the working class periphery.
That visa,
which I talked about before,
that's where I meet.
He says,
it's war between you and me.
Now,
baby,
uh,
lobby let,
[inaudible] here,
uh,
which was,
and it was indeed still at this time fairly a rural,
oh,
well,
you have to just all,
you know,
move your heads to see.
This is not a very interesting a photo,
but it's not hardly a photo.
But just to see that the,
uh,
the difference between 1850 and 18,
um,
uh,
in 1900,
the growth of,
of the suburbs now,
um,
and so this all involved the demolition of,
of uh,
uh,
great hills.
This was a hill at [inaudible],
which is a right to,
you know,
I'm the San,
uh,
and it put tens of thousands of,
of workers,
uh,
gave them something to do.
Now the principle of this is the re,
uh,
of the planning itself.
And this,
you know,
impacts,
uh,
this,
this course and the Paris of this course is really built upon classical
principles of associated with absolute monarchs.
Uh,
and I call it the imperialism of the straight line.
I in that,
um,
if you think of a city like St Petersburg built by Peter,
the great,
or if you think of my dream I built by Phillip the second,
or you think of Berlin and Frederick the grade,
or you think of Sy,
uh,
of rather prosperous suburb.
Uh,
they were,
they,
they were power alleys down which you march troops,
uh,
and very different than the kind of organic city that had grown up from medieval
origins.
The city like Strasbourg,
uh,
or for that matter Leone,
the Leone has some classical touches too in the plus Bella Cook and all of that.
But,
but here,
just to give you an obvious and,
and,
and almost banal example,
but I chose it because you already know about the avenue of the OPA,
Huh?
Uh,
for reasons,
um,
you know,
we talked about before is that this is pure imperialism of the straight line.
The problematic or the question is how you get,
you're going to build this big boulevard.
How do you get from,
uh,
the sen basically,
here's the root of Rivoli paralleling the sin to where you're going to build
this new magnificent opera that you saw before.
Well,
you don't have to be an architectural genius or Vincent Scully or something like
that.
You simply take a ruler and,
and then you tip off your friends about where the building is going to go.
So they make a lot of money and that's what this man did.
And you plan the Avenue to Lopa Huh?
And they're three reasons.
Three why Paris has rebuilt first to bring more light and air to Paris to make
it a healthier place,
more sewers and all that.
Second,
to free the flow of capital for capital to help business.
It's not a coincidence that the big department stores,
uh,
that grew up in the fifties and sixties are on the ground boulevard or on the
big boulevards.
And third,
and I've alluded to before,
how do you build a barricade across a huge boulevard across,
how do you build a barricade across the avenue?
Lopa Ha,
uh,
the first,
barricades in Paris,
uh,
we're in the late 16th century.
You know,
about the barricades.
Are you,
some of you do any way of the French revolution.
They're more barricades in 1830.
The more barricades in 1851,
you've seen photos of barricades from 1871 and [inaudible] says this.
And this memoirs,
we want to create barricade proof boulevards and world war two during,
um,
uh,
you know,
in a,
in August of 1944,
you know,
the bolt,
the barricades that are built against the German troops,
uh,
are built in neighborhoods often,
you know that where you have narrow streets.
And in 1968,
it's the same thing.
It was very hard to build a boulevard across the boulevard,
Sammy Shell or barricade across the boulevard,
San Michelle.
So that's the first thing.
And then you imagine you're looking down a,
uh,
you know,
you're looking at Johnny's opera,
which is going to rise out of the ground.
Uh,
the most expensive building a built in Paris to that point.
Um,
and then these houses with which are actually fairly middleclass buildings have
to be demolished.
So you are,
you were sitting in a bulldozer looking at through the smoke.
Uh,
and then there is a Yonnie's opera being built and there is gone.
The A's a opera,
uh,
right here.
And then of course,
that square now contains probably the largest,
uh,
population of pickpockets and a of this side of the Spanish steps as Americans,
tourists,
uh,
you know,
get off the metro.
They're looking for American Express with their wallets about to be soon to
disappear.
Um,
but,
uh,
and he,
and here you,
you know,
you can look down and see this is reversed but has make a but difference.
Uh,
uh,
you can see that's the plus Vendome the column of which was brought down in,
in uh,
in 1871 at core base,
uh,
um,
suggestion.
Uh,
and so you end up with this,
which you've already seen before.
The Avenue Lopera high,
and it was down here the for the first bomb that one replaced with down here at,
at number 11.
And so this is again,
a photo from 1900.
Um,
so this is,
uh,
basically there are a few automobiles racing around the nut racing that the
speed limit was three miles an hour.
Uh,
but,
uh,
now of course,
you know,
you're a dead duck if you try to cross.
Uh,
there,
uh,
there was somebody,
some general who was arrested,
some scandal and he just didn't testified.
And then he wasn't thinking he walked out into the street and was run over by a
bus.
Uh,
so you really kind have to watch it there,
but,
but here's your pure sir.
Oh,
Smollen vista of Paris.
Uh,
and,
and of course the,
the,
the balconies is her ornate balconies of the third republic are something that,
that,
uh,
one,
um,
identifies with the,
you know,
the grand juror of,
of,
of modern Paris,
the Paris of the belly book.
Now,
uh,
what about the people who were from the central districts?
This is a dot.
A very interesting print,
but it's still,
it was sympathetic to those people.
Uh,
if you rented,
most people didn't own apartments,
they rented.
And,
and if you were kicked out of your apartment in order to facilitate the building
of these boulevards,
you were,
uh,
given the equivalent robot a day's wages.
And that was it.
And here you have,
this is,
uh,
part two.
These are two lithographs and the first is called Osman is aweseome of that is
the bulldozing of the hospitalization of Paris,
part one where you see these people and they've got everything that they have.
You know,
they've got their dog and it's,
it's,
it's a,
uh,
it's a look.
It's a sympathetic look at them.
And this is part two,
and this is a pure,
oh,
[inaudible] vista.
This is,
uh,
very near the Oprah.
Aha.
This is the Church of Santa Augustine,
which I think is just God awful.
Uh,
but,
but here again,
you have the,
the,
the uh,
you know,
again the imperialism of the straight line.
And this is the big commercial district.
This is where the big department stores are near there.
Like the Gallery Lafayette and,
and uh,
and the,
uh,
at this time they go on magazine who move and,
and all these sorts of things.
So that's what,
that's the principle of,
of,
oh,
what's happened here of Bozeman?
Well,
that's,
you can hardly see that I'm a mess.
How do I turn this?
Uh,
is there any way I can turn this off?
Do you remember?
How do I do that?
Which was all of them there.
This for a sec so I can see it.
So if you,
if you were,
you're a bird flying around up here,
um,
and then,
or if you're in a balloon a and you're seeing the results of,
of,
of Ost Mon,
here again,
you've got Notredame,
which goes from the most populated part appointed Paris along with,
in my hay to the least populated part of Paris.
Why?
And we talk a lot about the state,
but the state buildings,
he's,
uh,
or state constructions,
including the big hospital Otalgia or their prefecture of police,
uh,
are built on,
on CTA.
And so the population,
uh,
departs this over here is the church of [inaudible] piece,
which had the,
one of the Great Oregon's,
and here,
uh,
this is the famous market of layout,
which was built at this time in the next to the church.
It was telling you stash,
and it lasted until till 1972 and they wouldn't,
uh,
they tore them all down and built a sort of miserable failure,
three floors of,
of crummy,
crummy,
a electronic stores.
And,
uh,
and they didn't even leave one.
So people,
I sound like a Scaly,
but,
uh,
it's true.
They didn't,
they wouldn't leave just one.
So people could see what was like,
what was the market.
And I was lucky to get,
first time I ever was in Paris,
uh,
when I was a kid,
somebody took me down there in the middle of the night and you could see the
butchers,
you know,
drinking,
uh,
with very sort of,
a free k,
very prosperous clients.
Uh,
uh,
eating,
at,
uh,
eating a big table,
next there.
And it was fantastic.
It was the guts of Paris was the heart of Paris and they just destroyed it.
Uh,
and they had to move the market to buy or the airport because Paris,
you know,
it's so big with 11 million people in the,
in the region now.
But it just,
it didn't make any sense to destroy them all.
It was so such vandalism,
just,
just incredible.
And it came of a time at the time of pumpy Doo who,
uh,
who said that we must renounce this outmoded aesthetic that has anything that
was beautiful and interesting and he was a patron of art,
of a modern art and all this worst forms.
But anyway,
um,
yeah,
my back.
But okay,
here's the,
uh,
the continuation of the root of Rivoli,
which had been begun by Napoleon and it gives you a major access,
uh,
that is west East.
Uh,
and,
and as we'll see in a minute,
he also creates a north south access because the,
or access,
what am I saying?
Well,
access to say the same thing.
So that just gives you a kind of a view from the top.
And here are,
uh,
here are these,
these,
uh,
Leon,
I mean,
this is the old market that was there and I was lucky cause you know,
it was gone about two or two years later or something like that.
And,
uh,
I had met a person who was kind enough to a lodge me in to take me,
down to,
um,
to see,
uh,
to see that and it's just gone.
Now.
They have yet another plan to,
to do something and it,
and it just becomes this,
oh,
it's,
well,
okay.
So,
uh,
again,
bringing,
freeing the flow of capital of commerce,
et Cetera,
was a worthy goal.
Indeed.
Uh,
and,
uh,
one of the things that the pulling in third did was just to celebrate France
with these expositions.
And of course,
the idea of having a big exposition is that of,
uh,
of the Victorians.
I mean,
the big one in 1851 at the Crystal Palace,
uh,
the first,
public toilets by the way,
uh,
at such things where in 1851 in,
in London,
and so I'm losing,
they Polian has other expositions that's when,
as 1854.
And so the principle of this,
as you walk down one of these exhibition halls and you look and you see
paintings on the right,
you see the wonders of science on the left,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
and millions of people go,
and that's the same principle as the department store,
isn't it?
Except that you can buy what you see.
Uh,
and the department stores,
what they do is they destroy local commerce.
Uh,
uh,
unless,
you know,
like boot makers and very skilled craftsmen are on the boulevards near the
department stores or provide the essential services in working class districts.
So,
uh,
the goal magazine,
Duluth is here.
I mean,
you have all the space.
It becomes a,
as I said,
the cathedral,
the modernity along with the others.
And now there are the equivalent of department stores in Paris.
And some of the arcades already in the 18,
not arcades in our,
but the arcades in the Parisian sense in the 18,
uh,
1820s.
And there,
there are even,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
prodo department stores exist before that,
but it's the fifties and sixties that brings to London and the Vienna and Berlin
and to Paris VA department store where you could buy,
you know,
40 different kinds of shawls,
cheap shawls to very fancy shoals.
So it's going to attract not only ordinary people looking occasionally for
bargains.
Uh,
and as I said before,
it's a form of,
of,
uh,
it creates jobs for working class and peasant women who become sales clerks
living in terrible conditions and kind of dormitories and almost prison like
rules.
But it also brings the,
the,
the free k,
the wealthy people will come in in their carriages and have their drivers await
them when they go in and listen to people sing Christmas carols on the stay on
the stairs.
And when electricity becomes,
you know,
common in the 1880s in 1890s,
you have these dazzling,
uh,
displays that,
that change in,
uh,
in,
you know,
uh,
in the,
the,
along the streets.
Uh,
and so they become a,
I mean,
we're really a site of tourism,
uh,
themselves.
Uh,
and so here's your basic idea is to create,
the problem is how do you get from,
this is north,
this is south,
uh,
and this is,
east this as West,
uh,
that there was no way of getting anywhere.
The two biggest streets in Paris in terms of,
of the most important ones were the Roussanne knee and the roof,
a seminar town.
A police don't remember these names.
Uh,
and so what they do is they create,
uh,
the boulevard stemi Shell,
which is a disaster here.
Uh,
and then because of,
you know,
Mcdonald's and all this stuff,
uh,
just awful,
just terrible zoning.
And then here,
uh,
what became the boulevard Sebastopol and Bula send a knee that goes out to the
railroad stations.
And of course,
what's mine is often castigated for having built a railroad stations next to
each other without having anticipated the automobile.
But how could he know about the automobile and the 1850s and sixties.
So they complete the sort of star,
the [inaudible] here,
which is the place of plots of the,
uh,
of the Arc de Triomphe.
Um,
and uh,
create,
uh,
you know,
he finishes the root to Rivoli,
uh,
here.
And of course as long that access as you saw that the troops come in May of
1851,
uh,
decimating the,
those who resisted in these neighborhoods.
So those are,
those are basically the plans that he wanted to,
to do.
So,
um,
here we go.
Uh,
this is the route or have a lead.
This is down,
it sort of completion.
This is heading east and the troops moved down this way.
Um,
and that,
uh,
it,
this parallels the sand.
This is the tower,
the remaining part of the tour of Sun Jock.
Uh,
that is there.
Um,
and then now this is looking north.
and,
uh,
you're crossing CTA now.
Uh,
this is where the police were that Shat delay in the 18th century.
But the point is that you see in the distance,
uh,
the station of the east,
the guy the last and so me,
it's very,
he's very successful.
He's not an intern.
I mean,
he's in many ways not an interesting man or smile.
I was asked to write a biography of him once and I didn't do it.
I gave it to someone else.
And of course,
Paris,
the Paris is the big story.
Uh,
but he,
I mean,
he was a fun function air.
He was a,
a technocrat,
uh,
but he was very good at what he did from repress people to building a
boulevards.
And,
and so,
I mean,
this is a success there.
It frees up,
uh,
the flow of circulation,
but it chases people like this.
Uh,
this is a pawn shop that still exists as the municipal pawn shop.
It's exactly the same space where it was at this time.
And anyone who looked at this would know,
uh,
what the image is because these people are so poor.
They are about to sell back their mattress number.
What I said that unless I'm wired,
that is your Vez dies like a dog and a bed of Straw.
Um,
more or less,
uh,
that,
I mean the,
the last dignity that you had was it's still have a mattress.
And when things got so bad,
that was what went the mattress.
And so these folks are carrying out carrying mattresses to,
uh,
try to get what they can from them.
And then you've got,
you know,
the,
the very poor down and out being expelled to the periphery even more.
This is a,
um,
uh,
this is,
a place where people who could get a little bit of food,
uh,
from charitable organizations.
This is in Monaca,
uh,
and I just put this in is around the corner actually from our apartment.
But uh,
uh,
this is,
a classic kind of Oh,
small building and architects had started to sign their work on the,
on the premiere.
Hey Taj,
on the,
on the second floor.
So this architect was called [inaudible] and it has the name,
the date there.
And these balconies are more ornate really than the ones that they did in
general at the time of oh,
smile.
And these are more sort of third republic ones,
but these are some very handsome buildings that,
uh,
that line,
this is that line of Boulevard at lines,
the inlines,
the,
uh,
the root of Tom.
Now and here we got a,
this is cracked.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
but this is the,
the station of the east.
And when I see the station and always case me twinge of sadness because in 1914,
all the people charging up to the station,
uh,
screaming Abela La Harbor Law to Berlin,
to Berlin.
And,
and uh,
you know,
this is one of the longer the station to the north.
I mean,
lead the troops to the front from which many of them,
most,
many of them,
a million and a half,
never returned.
Um,
and also,
uh,
so many from the stations.
So many Jews were rounded up by the Germans,
but above all by the French police,
uh,
in 1942 and 1943,
were sent on their way to draw a seat to the transit camp,
uh,
north of Paris,
and then onto,
uh,
onto the,
onto the death camps.
And,
uh,
again,
one of the themes is that all of this makes all of this makes this West East
division even more salient,
uh,
and makes the center periphery,
um,
uh,
contrast or juxtaposition even more important.
Uh,
Louis Napoleon had spent a lot of time in London.
He loved parks.
And so he,
he,
uh,
um,
he has them work on the water balloon and he blown.
Yeah.
And to the west of Paris,
fancy feeding the receiving people from the fancier corridors and these kinds of
Cafe Corsair,
uh,
along the shots.
Lycee are part of,
again,
of this east west,
a dichotomy.
Um,
they,
one can say,
oh,
math,
wait a minute.
Okay.
Um,
and then it's not to say that there weren't parks in the east.
This is the beauty show mall,
uh,
which is to the,
to the east.
And there's a lot of,
apparently a lot of real high stakes bull games are still are still played here.
So there were places,
uh,
Paris has very little green space compared to London and Berlin,
Berlin,
25% of Berlin is,
is a green space and lemons about the same thing.
Paris,
it's 5%.
Uh,
and then there's the [inaudible] which is out to the,
uh,
to,
to the east as well.
But here is again,
I mean this is your image of the Valet Paul.
Uh,
here you've got carriages carrying fancy people along.
You have the kiosk selling newspapers.
Uh,
you have trees.
You have these,
these boulevards that have been created by Oh Smuin now to be sure.
Now there were boulevards in European cities before Rosemont,
mine.
They tended to be on the outskirts of,
uh,
of,
of cities.
And,
and,
and they were built where there had been walls,
uh,
military fortifications in a way replaced ramparts of their mentor and down.
The best example,
and many may have you,
many of you may know this is Vienna with the Ring Sausa.
Uh,
which,
um,
was a really a creation of the liberal period in Vietnamese history.
I in the 1850s and sixties and seventies,
uh,
and which,
was on where there hadn't been fortified walls.
And in the case of Paris,
uh,
the best example is more Parnass,
Boulevard Mall Parnoss is on where there had been military fortifications,
but as Paris expanded,
the fortifications had to keep being pushed out.
So this is the boulevard,
a Masco here,
uh,
in 1900.
Um,
and then the,
the next one is the slide that,
that it will be a color picture.
Uh,
and this is a piece Aros view of that same,
um,
you know,
uh,
of that have that same boulevard.
And My,
my great friend Bob Herbert,
the fantastic a social historian of art actually found the place where a Beazer
are,
was looking out the window to,
to,
uh,
to do this.
But,
but here again,
I mean,
it's an obvious theme,
but,
uh,
you know,
the light and the movement of,
uh,
in the first painting,
what strikes you?
At the first glance,
a Paris was really,
uh,
the Paris of the boulevards were,
were really made for,
uh,
for the impressionist paintings.
And the only working class impressionist painter was when,
wow.
Uh,
and it was,
wow,
my quarter,
uh,
the other day who started out as a porcelain painter and limos,
a painting porcelain.
Uh,
and it was,
he that said that these boulevards reminded him of his soldiers lined up for
review.
Again.
I mean,
that's not a bad description of the imperialism of the straight line,
but the,
the,
it was these boulevards and its commerce and as wealthy people that,
that,
uh,
the anarchist so much,
Hayden,
um,
and again,
here,
this is a applause.
And,
and,
and this is through this intro of queer people that,
that,
that know something about impressionist painting.
Uh,
this became an impressionist painting a,
and I didn't get to slide,
um,
uh,
kind of an important,
street or intersection because,
uh,
the impressionists collector and painter Chi booked,
did his Paris,
uh,
you know,
the effect of the rain,
uh,
where he has a bourgeois couples,
crossing the street near each other,
but,
uh,
but having nothing in common with each other,
part of the anatomy of,
you know,
of the city.
Uh,
and it was a statement about the sort of self,
self,
self importance of the,
of the middle class and Sigma Chi books.
Other paintings involve,
uh,
views from balconies in which the person is the,
the viewer or the,
the,
the main subject of the painting is isolated from,
you know,
from ordinary people who might walk around a below I and you can,
you can over emphasize this themes do too much,
but it's still worth keeping in mind.
But,
but here you have your,
your,
you know,
your basic impressionist landscape.
Uh,
and it was very much a creation of their building of Paris in the 1850s and
sixties urban landscape.
So,
uh,
again,
I mean,
this is,
this is a,
a great example of the way in which,
you know,
not all boulevards were created by the [inaudible],
uh,
in Paris.
Some,
as I suggested a few minutes ago,
uh,
followed the roots of the walls.
And here's the best example one could pick.
Uh,
this was at the time of the French revolution.
the,
the city limits,
um,
eh,
the,
the two gates like this,
uh,
we're called the port,
the port to sound the knee and the,
uh,
um,
pull to up a pastime or settler.
I was just going to,
but anyway,
uh,
it was through a seminar town,
the port Soundmark town.
And,
um,
it was when Louie the 16th and Marie Antoinette,
uh,
tried to escape an improbably disguised as retainers for some,
you know,
wealthy Bareness.
Uh,
they were able to get through this,
this particular gate because the,
uh,
the,
the guards were bullied.
They were all drunk from,
uh,
having been in a wedding.
Um,
and then,
uh,
what the,
the tax collected and what you brought,
you brought into the city,
passed right through this gate.
You had to pay a tax on what you brought into the city.
More about that in a minute.
But you can see that these boulevards become extensions of,
uh,
become extensions of,
these walls that had once been there.
And in the case of the Port San Marta and the Potter and the knee,
uh,
they are still there.
And of course the ports done.
The knee is going north to,
uh,
to the cathedral town of Santa near village of [inaudible],
which be,
or small town,
which became a,
a,
an important,
uh,
senator of were working class a production and subsequently of anarchism
socialism and ultimately communism.
More about that in a minute.
Now,
I,
you still have traditional work done in Paris.
As I suggested,
we were talking about the garment industry and there's still had cases where the
father is literally the foreman and his family is working for him.
Uh,
you know,
through sub contracting,
people working,
uh,
working at what was a rather large,
you know,
this is an act lea.
This is not their,
their,
their home.
Uh,
well you've got pots and things hanging around a big roof.
Um,
but anyway,
in it's in the eastern part of Paris and in the northeastern and north and in
the suburbs that you've got the conversion of old buildings into industrial
production and you have new,
uh,
you have a new industries perched on the edge of the city.
And this is the room,
uh,
the full bowl of Sand Antoine,
which at the time of the French Revolution was beyond the busty.
And it was lots of these people who are cabinet workers,
uh,
who have storm the busty in the best deal in,
in 1789.
Um,
but again,
the contrast between center and periphery.
This is a somewhat sympathetic but also a little bit condescending.
Look at popular sociability in these cabaret that I talked about the other day,
uh,
on the edge of,
the perception,
the middleclass perception of the drunk and commoner perched on the edge of,
uh,
urban life on the margins of urban life,
drinking it up.
And,
and these are really great.
This is a,
here I put these next to in simply to show you the difference between our give
you images of the differences between the,
what happens to the western districts of Paris on the edge and those of the
east.
Now this is,
this is the east,
uh,
on the very edge.
And uh,
uh,
these are so rural looking houses,
you know,
was slanted roofs like that.
This is the laundry of combat.
So this is a real kind of socialist image from the,
uh,
the turn of the century.
Uh,
this has gotta be right before World War One.
How do we know that?
Um,
because this is something of the May 12 and the first metro opened along the Sin
Paralleling the sin,
uh,
on July 14th,
1900 four,
the exhibition,
it's now the line that goes to the [inaudible] phones all the way out to vest
then,
uh,
to the east.
And then the lines were subsequently extended out.
So,
uh,
this is probably about 1912 and 1913.
Uh,
but this is still a kind of a,
this is the,
these are a industrial suburbs that have been created by both,
uh,
you know,
the industrial glomeration of Paris,
the availability of land and have,
uh,
of capital on the outside of Paris and of,
of,
of a workforce of a very transient,
uh,
but still a massive workforce there.
And then if we go off in the other direction on the edge of this would be what
the equivalent now as of the 17th or own these small,
I reversed this,
but it doesn't make this size,
but a difference.
You see that this is a,
you know,
this,
this building is,
is,
you know,
sort of a solidly,
uh,
artists will,
Laura Middleclass building,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
you know,
that reflects the fact that in many ways,
uh,
the western half of Paris and including even the western periphery was,
was,
uh,
was very different.
Um,
I mean,
I,
I say that with,
with,
uh,
some,
I mean,
once you get the image that all the suburbs in the west were like zero Psi
Argent arch.
And Toy,
for example,
five people broke into the museum,
they'll say over the weekend,
and for some whatever reason,
they're all drunk up,
poked a big hole in,
in and Monet's great.
Uh,
uh,
the bridge at Arjun toy painting,
which is really kind of a amazing damage.
But Arjun,
ty was a place where,
uh,
you had,
you had leisure,
you had sailboats,
you had people of means a,
you no longer had vineyards at all.
Uh,
but you also had industry and Monet,
the painter,
Claude Monet,
his depictions of Arjun Toy.
Uh,
uh,
you have the smoke stacks become just part of the scene.
It's a very neutral kind of look at,
at smokestacks of it.
Not clearly differentiated even from,
you know,
from these sailboats are in the regattas and all of that.
But,
but Monet,
and it's my friend Bob Herbert who pointed this out,
um,
won't even,
he lives at ours and tie.
He gets tired of that.
He gets tired of kind of the contradictions of,
of,
you know,
of capitalism and industrialization.
And,
and,
and he longs for this,
uh,
this,
this nonurban,
uh,
pay Sij this law,
non urban scenes to pain.
And what does he do?
As you all know,
he moves to Giovanni is given a knee along the,
uh,
along the sin and a railroad track runs right through his back,
his backyard.
And he never paints it.
Not once.
What he does is he creates this kind of,
uh,
this kind of idyllic,
rural scene of,
you know,
lily pads and ponds and,
and,
uh,
it's a wonderful experience to go there if you're not trampled by that,
you know,
40,000 tourists,
uh,
you can imagine this is someplace where someone lived and ran up and down the
stairs and had fun and,
and,
uh,
and then went out and got away from this industry of ours origin toy.
Uh,
but anyway,
he was moving on to a different stage.
And so what you,
you know,
what you get on,
on the edge of Paris?
I is,
uh,
and the West is this,
this is the avenue of the grown to Almay.
So this is beyond the Arc de Triomphe.
And now this is going out to New York,
which is a,
you know,
a very,
uh,
right on the edge of the water balloon,
which was a,
I became a very,
very prosperous,
uh,
a suburban certainly still is.
That's it,
that's for sure.
Um,
and,
uh,
what you had on the other side of the east was very different and the north and
northeast was,
was,
it was extremely different.
It wasn't like that at all.
And so what happens,
um,
when you,
you know,
the images that I showed you before of those big arcs of triumph that in which
you,
uh,
which I said the king had escaped through trying to get out of France during the
French revolution.
Um,
and I said that you paid on what you brought in and just,
you know,
in conclusion for the last seven minutes,
I'm going to talk a little bit about,
uh,
a theme that's rather interesting.
And that's why European suburbs are so different than American suburbs.
More about that in a minute.
But,
um,
the,
the walls around Paris when they lost their military purposes,
still had a fiscal purpose,
which was to provide a means of collecting taxes on what you brought in to town.
And this wall or this taxing apparatus is called in French,
the Oak Trois Oct Roi.
And I love these little buildings.
You can see some at,
uh,
on the,
in your necio and pleasant enough show you and the other cop cow and a lot,
there's a fantastic one.
I mean,
seem all over the places and they're just beautiful.
Sometimes people live in them,
but this,
but this last,
this isn't something that disappeared in 1850 or 1900.
It lasts till World War Two.
And that's,
that's the big way that municipalities were able to raise any money at all since
basically wealthy people didn't pay taxes.
Uh,
and that's why it's a very regressive tax.
It's like a huge super sales tax.
And Francis,
nothing was not full of regressive taxes.
Uh,
since the value added tax is 21%.
And on electronics and stuff like that is 33%.
So,
uh,
you're taxed on what you buy and sell.
It's poor.
People have left less money to buy things.
It's,
it really is a totally unfair but,
but the origins of the system is in the [inaudible] and this is one of those are
actually fairly rare photos that I know of of what it was like in your sort of
divulge Joss,
your coach here.
This is called an [inaudible] out.
It was people wrote on the top and,
and you're leaving Paris or you entering Paris.
It doesn't matter at all.
But the point is that you were controlled day or night when you went through and
on the edge of Paris is a,
are created the,
these,
these working class industrial suburbs,
uh,
that are feared by the center and during the 1920s and 1930s become major
sources of support for the Communist Party.
I,
because people,
most of the people will live there,
were extremely badly lodged.
And the Communists do very well because of the model look,
t that has people who are badly lodged and they provide services to poor working
families that,
and other municipalities simply one did not have.
And if you go to something like the fact that in many ta,
which is the big communist party,
every year,
a big boom,
a big guy,
which means a big,
big party,
you know,
with full of speeches and all of that,
you could kind of go from one booth and have your oysters and the Feeney stair
booth and then go have paya and the [inaudible] booth,
and then,
uh,
you know,
have goat's cheese and the l dash booth,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And Beaujolais and the,
and the,
uh,
in the hone booth,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
but,
but the association between,
between working class people on the edge of a,
on the margins of the big city,
uh,
and radical politics is terribly important in the twenties and thirties.
And even much later than that.
Um,
and this is a,
a town called [inaudible],
which is north of Paris and they all have streets called something like the
rumor he's tall,
has,
who was a mining a minor,
who was a leader,
a leader of the Communist Party following the dictates of Moscow.
Alas,
in the 19,
um,
uh,
in the 1930s,
many of them still have an avenue,
genre has,
uh,
for obvious reasons,
reasons,
but so,
but this is this,
the growth of all of,
of the,
of these industrial suburbs that is one of the important,
uh,
sort of concomitance of,
of large scale industrialization and the identification of the urban periphery
with industrial work,
I mean many of the so called dirty industries chemical production.
So production things that smell are forced out of the center,
uh,
and onto the periphery.
And so that's where the factories are.
That's where the cheapest labor is to be found more about this.
And just a second,
and just to finish this off with a Monet of Arjun tie again,
and this one does,
it's not the poem ours and tell you if I had a time,
it would have gone to get that one.
The painting,
it was just a rip by vandals over the weekend.
Uh,
but,
uh,
again,
the extension of,
of the sort of prosperity to the West is obviously the Norman coast because
they're pretty with a turbo trains are already going to the northern coast.
Deauville is not far away a Choctaw,
uh,
you know,
and these kinds of places are there.
And so that's an extension of this west East,
uh,
a dichotomy,
in that,
that people from eastern Paris or from the northern suburbs are not going to
[inaudible] for the weekend.
They're not.
The kind of people are going to be painted by Beth Kimonti zone.
Uh,
uh,
but so the spatial concomitants are aspects even,
you know,
continue to,
is for the planting of the Parisian flag on the Norman coast.
And again,
that's a subject for another excellent book,
uh,
by my friend,
Bob Herbert.
Now I want to get the finish off.
I want to get somewhere more light so I can see you all.
Um,
um,
how to do this,
how to do this in five minutes.
I will do this in the following way.
In 1991,
was it 1991 or 1992 at the time of the Rodney King riots does that,
1992,
um,
uh,
Rodney king was a,
an Afro American and lay in La.
And the police basically just beat the hell out of him.
I,
and,
uh,
there's a there,
they're acquitted and it,
it led to some,
uh,
very,
very difficult times in,
in Los Angeles with,
with lots of riots and,
and,
uh,
lots of anger.
And we were doing a bunch of us,
uh,
an edited book on,
on the red suburbs,
on precisely this,
in,
in working class suburbs in they're sort of identification with radical
politics.
And people in France kept asking me,
they couldn't understand the concept of,
of wealthy suburbs and impoverished people,
minorities living in the center of cities and find the weed.
They stopped even press.
Well,
I could write something and not kill of me,
but I just,
Reno wrote something,
an epilogue trying to explain why it is that in Europe things are different now.
I,
and it's not entirely so after,
after all [inaudible] was a suburb in the early 1830s,
one of the ministers of Louis Felipe went to him and said,
sir,
if these factories that you are allowing the prefect of police to tolerate on
the edge of the city will be the core that rings are net one day.
Fear of the periphery,
not fear of,
of the center.
Uh,
in 1831 and 1834,
[inaudible] the,
the suburb of the Qua who's the soap workers pour down the hill down the hill,
defending their rights with scientists,
had live free and die fighting.
And the middleclass national guard set up their guns to right at the edge of the
city,
uh,
to keep the suburban people from invading the center.
That's very,
very different,
isn't it?
Lee?
Moshe,
same thing.
They put up barricades,
the workers in the suburbs,
the differentiate their space with,
with the center.
Uh,
it is amazing.
Amazing kinds of continuity.
The,
the,
these,
these sort of mutual fears in Detroit in 1968 when I was a kid,
uh,
there was a 1967 I went to a tiger game and we came out of the tiger game
doubleheader with the Yankees and the city was on fire and it was the riots of
Detroit.
And much of Detroit is still decimated,
has never recovered from that,
never despite the Renaissance Center and the occasional success of the tigers
and all good things like that.
And one of the,
of the suburbs of Detroit tried at 1.2 to change the street patterns so that
they,
that is the poor people from the center could not come out to gross point or
Farmington hills or one of those elegant places.
And I remember that very,
very vividly.
Now,
why did that all happen?
Y and we talk in two years ago,
we had all these big riots in,
in,
in France,
in the,
in the suburbs and began in clichy soup Wa and you know,
all over the place.
I mean,
some were exaggerated and all of that.
And Sarcozi spun it out of control by calling them scum that people live in the
periphery.
They're scum rack rack guy is exist,
the guy and all this stuff.
It's just,
it was,
it was just the policy.
Uh,
how did this happen?
You know,
what happened is that the,
that people unwanted by the center,
we're in creating [inaudible] was part of this rejected toward the outside where
with the,
you know,
the dilapidation of,
of American Center cities,
a good part of Philadelphia did most of Detroit,
I mean New Orleans,
New Orleans,
uh,
San Francisco and you know,
Beacon Hill and put when we can find exceptions to that,
but the pattern's just completely different.
You had the Vietnamese,
uh,
army firing,
you know,
large shells at the working class,
suburbs at the housing,
uh,
working class housing on the outside of the city.
It's just the opposite.
When you think of suburbs,
uh,
you don't just think of Darienne or you don't just think of gross point or
Hillsborough,
California or,
uh,
you know,
very fancy places,
uh,
in other places.
But I mean,
it's,
it's very different.
The F,
it's a pattern is just the opposite.
It's an incredible difference.
And when,
can't exaggerate this too much,
but,
but these spatial tensions count for something.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
the margins of urban life in,
in France and a particularly around Paris were really,
uh,
the,
the periphery became the,
uh,
became the domain of people who,
who really couldn't afford to live in the center.
And that's an increasing problem in Paris today is one neighborhood after
another becomes more and more expensive.
Now it's 11th and 12th are out of control.
The 13th is audit control.
And,
uh,
3 million people may live in Paris,
but you've got another 8,000 people living in this urban agglomeration and
creating these attempted cities that are gonna,
that are gonna be magnitude of their own.
It's been an utter,
utter failure.
But when almost mine was really part of that,
and,
uh,
people building factories seek a labor force,
they seek more space.
They want to have their factories outside of the customs barrier,
so they're not paying taxes on what they bring in to use in their factory.
So that's just a very short explanation for why European cities and European
suburbs in particular,
the whole sense of a suburb.
Uh,
you know,
despite the kind of poverty,
all of a Remy Central,
a Samurai Raimi,
they show videos and places like that.
Uh,
and there was a wealthier parts of the other Parisian periphery.
There's still a contrast there.
And even the image,
when you say you're in French,
you say,
ah,
you know,
you come from the capto vans because you come from 93,
that means since then the knee and that it for them that that's the image of the
93 license plate is that the of the periphery,
uh,
of,
of people who are thought to be marginal by the center.
But as I've argued in other places,
including some of my own writing,
the sense of not belonging to the center creates a type of solidarity that
helped the communist in the 1920s and thirties.
And,
and,
and hopefully people,
you know,
as the government is undercut the temps of,
of,
of suburban people to create voluntary associations that will,
we'll offer hope to all these people.
Wait Til your watch to the end,
you know,
the film,
uh,
later on.
It's incredible.
Well,
some of this starts with those mine.
We went along way today from the l station until all the way to clichy,
uh,
why,
two years ago.
But I hope that the larger points were clear.
And from that,
we move on to,
uh,
to imperialism on Monday.
I have a fantastic weekend.
See you.